[Musique]
le célèbre marque par cette remise du
prix du livre d'histoire sont
attachement à l'histoire aux historiens
et le Sénat est très attaché à cela
comme assemblée parlementaire parce que
dans un monde où la vie politique est
souvent gagnée par la tyrannie de
l'immédiateté la profondeur historique
permet souvent de réfléchir un peu mieux
aux événements d'actualité que nous
avons à affronter
[Musique]
ce livre s'intitule les Illuminati de la
société secrète aux théories du complot
c'est un livre en fait que j'ai voulu
consacrer et adresser un large public
sur un sujet sensible puisque c'est
celui de la conspiration tout ce qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui des théories du
complot y compris la dimension sanitaire
les vaccins etc on leur a attribué à un
moment donné la paternité donc c'est
faire vraiment une histoire de nos peurs
aussi bien ancienne que les peurs
d'aujourd'hui
[Musique]
au fond c'est une réflexion sur le
complotisme qui est le grand adversaire
de la démocratie et par la même ce livre
répond exactement aux trois critères que
nous nous fixons c'est à dire la qualité
des recherches d'autre part son
accessibilité
un large public et enfin pour sa portée
civique nous sommes au Sénat et nous
n'oublions jamais que l'ouvrage que nous
choisissons doit répondre aussi de la
nécessité d'instruire les citoyens qui
le souhaitent
quand Ryana fait un spectacle où elle
porte un carnet où il est écrit Princess
au Illuminati vous imaginez
qu'instantanément elle devient leur chef
de fil Mathias Castle par exemple qui a
produit une chanson qui s'appelle
Illuminati 666 donc là on a tout le
démon la référence nazi aux
illuminatatons qui date quand même du
siècle des Lumières donc ils ont une
capacité à être bien malgré eux
complètement
revisité
relooker en permanence dans une
perspective d'expliquer nos peurs